jérôme rodriguez relaxé par le tribunal
judiciaire de paris s'il était jugé pour
injures publiques
les précisions de notre reporter bassin
chebbi jérôme rodriguez ali dehors des
gilets jaunes relaxé par la justice et
l'état et le syndicat synergie officiers
déboutés de leur demande
suite à ces échanges de tweets entre le
gilet jaune et le syndicat de police où
jérôme rodriguez qualifié la police
nationale de nazis deux ministres de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin avait réagi
et porté plainte contre le gilet jaune
pour défendre l'honneur des policiers
c'est qu'il avait déclaré le 24 janvier
dernier monsieur rodriguez passer devant
le tribunal et à la barre il avait
assumé son tweet et avait déclaré si tu
mettras limyè son avocat que ses propos
visaient l'institution et non pas des
policiers en particulier l état ainsi
que le syndicat de police avait demandé
à la justice un euro symbolique pour
dommages et intérêts et que jérôme
rodriguez puisse prendre l'entièreté des
frais de justice alors que m halimi
l'avocat de jérôme rodriguez avait
demandé la relaxe le tribunal a statué
et a prononcé la relaxe du gilet jaune